but also attorney general barr
has stated that he and the justice
department this is president's trump
justice department has seen no
widespread fraud
we have had they have had multiple
investigations like us
and our investigators have seen no
widespread fraud
either even after this office request
that president trump try and quell the
violent rhetoric
being born out of his continuing claims
of winning
the states where he obviously lost he
tweeted out
expose the massive voter fraud in
georgia
this is exactly the kind of language
that is at the base of growing threat
environment for election workers
who are simply doing their jobs
we will continue to do our jobs follow
the law
and follow the process now let's get
into that process
yesterday there were special runoff
elections in georgia
kwanzo hall has been elected to finish
the remainder of the term
of john lewis congratulations
congressman elect kwanza hall
sonia halpern will represent state
senate district 39
in the coming session and finally
deborah gonzalez will be the district
attorney in the western district
which is comprised of clark and oconee
mountain
oconee counties and i had served in the
house with
deborah gonzalez these elections were
run by election and poll workers doing
their jobs
this is a service to our community these
workers are your neighbors
you go to church with them you shop in
the same stores
and your kids go to the same schools
they don't deserve
what is being thrown at them now on to
the recount
we have had about 110 counties that have
finished their work
in our continuing conversations with the
counties
we anticipate all of them will make our
midlight deadline
we'll be putting up the reporting site
up at 2 00 pm today
we have seen no substantial changes to
the results from any county so far
and that's what we expected and i think
that's what most other people have also
and i want to thank again all those
hard-working election officials in all
159 counties
who continue to do so and continue to do
their jobs
methodically and professionally
for january 5th we are at 983
7735 absentee about request
so far and county's already accepted
11 474.
lna testing logic and accuracy testing
will begin this week for the early vote
for this election that begins at only 12
days
all across georgia believe that january
5th
is where people should be expending
their energy we need to look ahead
to control the united states senate and
a statewide public service commission
seat are at stake now on monday and
tuesday what we've been talking about is
some of these outside independent groups
contacting people and what they said is
they said they were using our voter file
but that's not true here's something
that came to our house
yesterday we got three of them all from
the same organization
and it's to my son brenton j
raffensberger who passed away
two years ago almost two and a half
years ago he's not on our voter files
here in georgia we checked
so i just want to let you know that what
they say
can't be supported by the facts on the
ground and we have proof
in our own home and so we're calling
that out we called it out monday and
tuesday
this came yesterday so just interesting
how timing works out that way
i'm grateful for all those who serve
their communities i want to extend grace
to those
that seemingly have hate in their heart
we've all been through an awful lot
as many of us have said we wish that our
guy would have won the election but
it doesn't look like our guy has won the
election and like
vice president biden will be carrying
georgia and who is
our president-elect i encourage all of
you to stay engaged
advocate for your values policies and
goals you believe argue persuade and
engage
but do so peacefully we are a nation of
laws
and not of men we have to remember that
we have systems and policies and
procedures and institutions that have
served
us well we do well to secure protect and
enhance those institutions
to further protect and defend our
constitution
good morning
i'm gabe roaster only voting system
implementation manager state of georgia
this one minor update on specifics
around the recount
we got a call in this morning that
fulton county
on monday when they had completed the
hand audit
for some reason thought there likely
wouldn't be a recount to sort of boxing
everything back together
including the absentee in person which
is the early vote
and the election day votes in the
similar boxes so on monday
they accidentally scanned i don't know
how many boxes but some number of boxes
of
advanced voting into the election day
bucket of votes
so their plan right now when they
discover this is they're going to
do their plan today which is to scan
through the largest amount of ballots
which is absentee in person
and then the end of the day rescan all
of those
ballots that they had scanned originally
on monday which is the smallest amount
of balance which is the election day by
53
000. it's about 315 000 uh
advanced in person and 53 000
uh election day votes they should still
make the deadlines they have 17 scanners
going they got started about an hour
late this morning
and just to respond to the fulton
elected officials saying show us some
proof
there's some proof i mean it's just
consistently having things like that
and they're they just stack up and they
on to each other
and it cascades and again they're the
largest county
they have special situations they have
to deal with they have more to deal with
anybody else i think one of the biggest
things we've seen is
they have generals and they have
privates and they have very little
management in the middle of those things
to have
processes in place and that's one of the
things we continue to see there that's
unfortunate
um they have all of our counties had a
lot on them as the secretary said i mean
most these people didn't sign up for
this but um those are the big the
details we have on that the secretary
said we're going to be launching the enr
site election night reporting site at
two o'clock today
you'll get to see everything that exists
as it's already been uploaded and
they'll continue to upload through the
night
and we have given a deadline to the
counties that if they do have a change
in the outcomes they're going to
recertify at the county level
by noon on friday and then we take all
those changes in
we will then certify that afternoon
and as i understand at that point that
the governor may have to recertify again
and send that up to
the elector's list again to dc so with
that i'll take any
office questions saying you have
properly purged 198 000 people from the
lord rules
did you purge 119
i'm gonna go with no
frankly i've not seen or heard of this
lawsuit yet but we follow a federal law
which basically says
there's a window of 90 days before any
federal election
in for georgia essentially we had the
presidential preference in march
and let's not call it a purge it is
federally mandated
list maintenance no one's getting purged
let's be very clear on this
your name remains in our on our books if
you move away to georgia and you move
back you get the same voter id number we
know who you are
nobody's being removed who's not
supposed to be already removed
there are three ways to get on that list
and i'm probably going to forget what at
this point
because i've been a while since i had to
talk about this because in 2020 we don't
do any list maintenance
you can get you die so then you're off
there's ncoa the national change of
address and that
gets loaded on and we look at those
things to compare the ones
there there's the return mail
which is if the post that the uh
elections office the county election
sends you something and it gets returned
to them they then send you another
letter saying hey are you still there
if you don't answer that then you can
put on the inactive list then it's like
depending on where the election cycles
fall and the new law we pass
in 2019 it's either seven or ten years
before you get removed from the
from having being an active or an active
person you go to cancel status
so i'm going to go with no on that i
know our processes and procedures
and i'm shocked to even hear that
anybody's even
attempting to do that at this point when
we have so much so many bigger fish to
fry
yes ma'am
i'll find out i didn't read the book i
just saw that this morning when i walked
in he was
not happy about that yes sir have you
heard directly from the president of the
white house
me no seriously i do not believe he has
either
i mean you saw the response of the tweet
about what was stated here yesterday
then it was simply to ignore it more
than anything and keep on doing what he
was doing
anybody else yes
i don't know i i think we have to do it
within seven days uh but they we still
do the ballot run there's
a special there's several steps we got
to go through but it'll be pretty
quickly and then once he gets certified
he can go up and get sworn in for the
remainder of the term which will be up
until i guess the swearing in
of nakima williams
similar is the uploading process
it's going to be relatively similar um
they don't have many cards to put into
the ems on the front end but they're
going to be able to just basically take
the
jump drive and put it into the enr we're
using the same sidle system we normally
use so it'll look the same to everybody
as well
well when you keep on kicking over rocks
and keep on finding new things it always
expands the timeline of the
investigation so
i don't have a timeline yet i'm not an
investigator we do talk to francis
watson our chief investigator regularly
to see where we stand on these things
but remember we have 250 active
investigations
just from 2020 the majority of which
have been coming from the general
election
and i think 18 of which surround
absentee ballots then we have these new
ones coming in about third-party groups
and i'm not sure how many of those
qualify and the ones that are trying to
potentially encourage people to commit
felonies by registering illegally
but we are continuing a pace on trying
to track these things down and
part of this is about making sure they
act responsibly
third-party groups have every right to
register people they don't have a right
to encourage people to break the law
to you know confuse and frighten people
by sending things to their dead
relatives
and then it undermines the overall
confidence in the system the same way
the president's trump comments are
i mean i find it somewhat ironic that
stacey abrams is coming out and claiming
the higher moral ground because she set
the stage for a lot of this by
her claims the system was rigged it's
the same
thing two sides of the same coin and
both of them undermine
the system of boasting under my
democracy i was talking to a friend of
mine from dc yesterday
he said it was crazy how the left was
undermining their own voters from
believing in the system and now it's
crazy that the right is doing the same
thing we're seeing
now the left is exploiting that we see
these billboards up saying that
lefleur and and purdue were not there
for trump we don't need to be there for
them
discouraging people from voting is not
the right way to go about this
fight about your values argue engage
persuade win over the votes all the
stuff we're talking about here is
election administration
everybody has the same access to these
things a drop
go to let's go to the drop boxes real
quick that you know some people some
republicans are upset about drop boxes
they say it encourages valor harvesting
this secretary passed a law that
outlawed battle harvesting for the first
time
and if you really want to talk about
what's less secure
the drop boxes are monitored 24 hours a
day by video cameras
a united states postal service box isn't
so somebody could walk in with 300
you know stamped envelopes and put them
into a usps box and it's less secure
than them they're trying to do it under
video surveillance
all these steps are there evenly for
everybody
how you choose as a campaign and as a
party as a consultant or whatever to use
them
is up to you in my life in my old life i
used to be able to consult i guess some
people know that now after the last 24
hours
i say however the hell you want to vote
go do it
and i'll encourage you to do it that way
and we loved banking votes early in
early voting we loved banking votes in
absentee
it was a great way to make sure you got
those players off the field you could
focus on who was left
i mean some of this stuff is blocking
and tackling for both parties um
but it's important to realize that what
we do
is we set the stage we set the playing
field and everybody has to follow the
same rules and everybody has the same
opportunities that is the goal
that is the goal yes ma'am
okay take it off i can't hear you
yes
if it's if it's one vote different they
have to re-certify so that's that's what
we're really seeing is one two three off
you know
and if somebody's going to come down to
the adjudication differences the hand
marked absentee ballots
where you see all the issues the bmd
ballots are great because there's
no doubt who they voted for voter intent
is absolutely certain
but the hand mark here ballast ones
where we see adjudication look at it
differently
there might be an overvote that wasn't
caught before or adjudicated slightly
differently
than it was in the earlier both the hand
audit and the earlier account
so if it's off by one vote difference
they have to recertify that particular
election
and then if one county has to recertify
one vote then the state has to do the
entire recertification again so
we do know those counties exist i do not
have a count of them hopefully by this
afternoon i can tell you
in fact we could probably all look at
the enr site by the time we do another
press conference
and we'll know exactly how many there
are yes sir
i know we were particularly we were
invited to participate in at least one
and i think any discussion of election
process can be helpful on the education
side
because what happens is what's happening
right now in large part is the president
and his lawyers are exploiting a lack of
understanding of a lot of these
situations the situation we saw in
gwinnett
that was being you know looked at by
people who have zero clue
about how elections works was spun up
into something
of data manipulation when the
this young man was simply i'll say it
again
just to clarify the election management
system is the sort of the brains of the
election operation there is a report on
there
called a batch report which basically
says we have done this many batches
there are this many ballots in these
batches and he was taking that report
off
because to save money there is no excel
on the
ems because there's a license yet to pay
for that so they took it over to the
county computer
and having no understanding of that we
have people out there from q anon and
other things
say this man is committing treason
they're exploiting the lack of
understanding they're exploiting
people's fears
and that's what leads to us so any
opportunity to answer these kinds of
questions
to the senators or representatives or
anybody who who wants to have a better
understanding of how the system's
working about the real security
and process we have in place will be
welcomed
somewhere else yes in the general
election
runoffs are a completely different
election and whether you voted in it or
not you can vote
in the upcoming runoff as you're if
you're a registered voter in georgia
that's fine
all right yes sir
yes we have a cut off deadline for the
counties to re-certify by noon on friday
and we will do it at some point after
that once we get all the final uploads
to make sure everything is correct
all right thank you all very much have a
great day
oh
you can read
has the mask information been given
i now recognize myself for four minutes
to give an opening statement
today the committee convenes to conduct
oversight over the treasury departments
and federal reserve's pandemic response
this pandemic continues
to have a terrible impact across the
nation
there have been over 13.4 million
violence cases in the us which is almost
double the amount of cases
when the secretary and chair last
testified
in september and over 267 thousand
people have lost their lives to the
virus hospitalizations and deaths
are surging as this crisis spirals
out of control small businesses are
shutting their doors
permanently and millions are at risk of
eviction
foreclosure and being laid off a
historic number of americans
resoundingly voted for a new direction
last month
by overwhelmingly voting for
president-elect biden
and vice president-elect harris the
american people have made it clear
that they want a government that will
fight this virus
and will protect their families and
small businesses
from the impacts of covert 19.
[Applause]
so secretary mnuchin on a call last
month
many committee uh democrats and i
committed to not going home until we
have a deal
or a stimulus package that is
desperately needed across the country
but as negotiations continue i'm
appalled
uh that you would normally make matters
worse by permanently ending essential
emergency lending programs leaving state
students and small businesses
out to dry as the nation faces a dire
and worsening phase of the pandemic
crisis and
there's simply no justification or just
a viable reason
to take these tools away with the
pandemic crisis worse
than it has been in the biden
administration arriving
in january and sharon paul i'm
also concerned that the federal reserve
acceded to tracer's request
after publicly indicating the importance
of extending these facilities
secretary mnuchin i'm also very
concerned that the treasury department
may be taking actions that will
undermine our housing markets during the
pandemic
by reportedly working with the federal
housing finance agency to rush to
government
sponsored enterprises out of
conservative ships
before the end of the trump
administration
and so these actions follow
the trump administration's obstruction
of the transition process
delaying important information sharing
about the pandemic response and national
security
between the biden transition team and
the current administration
so today you will be held to account for
your
misguided actions before recognizing the
ranking member of the committee
the gentleman from north carolina who's
with us today
i'm going to make sure that our
witnesses
are received responsibly
in a way that they should be received
and thank them for being here
and so prior to that
um i would normally
recognize them i suppose at this point
however
i think that uh as the agenda has been
laid out today
um i'm going to go ahead and recognize
the gentleman
from north carolina mr mchenry for four
minutes
well thank you madam chair and look um i
know there's been a lot of partisan talk
by my
uh colleagues on the democratic side of
the aisle
attacking the actions of the treasury
secretary
and even federal reserve um and
i know committee democrats and a lot of
democrats in congress said that
they wouldn't go home until they had a
deal and then
uh they went home for 10 days so
there's not a whole lot of uh
believability coming
uh from uh our fellow politicians here
on capitol hill right now
it's quite frustrating uh but chairman
powell um
secretary mnuchin i want to thank you
for being with us today and being
so available um i also want to commend
you
for the quick and decisive work that you
both have taken
um and and and i think that that is uh
that is something we should commend you
for
but today i think there's also a reason
for optimism the coronavirus vaccines
are moving at an unprecedented pace
last month pfizer announced its vaccine
is 95
effective and they're currently seeking
regulatory clearance moderna
announced on monday its vaccine is 94.1
percent effective
and will also seek regulatory clearance
the the british
announced today uh that they're moving
forward uh
as well with it with their vaccine
distribution this is proof that the
public-private partnerships like those
in operation warp speed can lead to
phenomenal successes and record time
but we know we know a full economic
recovery will occur
only when americans can go back to work
safely send their kids back to school
confidently
and have easy access to testing and
treatments there's still more work to be
done
and and so i do want to go back to
our committee jurisdiction the treasury
and the feds decisive actions
uh back in march and april to prevent
the worst
of this economic crisis and saving
millions of jobs
chairman powell the federal reserves of
may emergency lending facilities
continue to serve as a strong backstop
uh to our financial markets and
and prevent uh disorder in the financial
markets from impacting our real economy
uh those those uh programs stipulated
billions of dollars in private sector
lending and successfully
operated as lender of last resort and
now
they acted as a that necessary source of
liquidity
in those urgent times earlier this year
they ensured the orderly
flow of credits and and the functioning
of markets of all sizes
including supporting workers and
communities across the country so i want
to commend you for that
but they are emergency facilities only
and they're backstops
designed to support the functioning of
private markets and they're intended
uh to be a lender of last resort not to
replace
private markets and from the start i've
said that we need to be forward thinking
and have a plan to wind down these
firefighting measures when appropriate
and so
i want to thank uh both the fed and
treasury
uh for uh having a plan to wind those
measures
down appropriately as accordance to the
cares act
law um and i also know that uh
and i will ask you specifically about
this about uh the additional capacities
that you will have with the cares act
uh expiring on on january on december
31st
uh additionally secretary mnuchin thank
you
for your quick work on the paycheck
protection program that supported
millions of small businesses
um and i know we still need uh
additional relief for
more small businesses in different
segments and thank you for continuing to
work for a bipartisan
agreement here on capitol hill um and uh
to not play the gamesmanship and
partisan games uh
that uh that have uh bedeviled um
uh these talks uh in the last couple of
months thank you for
for rising above that um so but they're
still
done and uh i look forward to us coming
together and having packaged
small businesses and do the responsible
things necessary
to help our economy to protect
american citizens thanks so much for
being here today and look for your
testimony
you're back thank you very much and now
recognize the chair of the subcommittee
on oversight and investigations mr green
for one minute thank you madam chair i
thank the witnesses for appearing as
well
indicating that the market has been
significantly
this begs the question for my
constituents what markets
the real federal market billion
the free food market the food is the one
thing in common
as the whole food is gone
in october the stock market does not
measure certain things that are
occurring to my constituents
uh
[Music]
my concern today is what is your agency
doing
to help the grim reality of this
pandemic
i look forward
thank you very much i now recognize the
subcommittee's ranking member
mr barr for one minute uh thank you
madam chair and thank you to our
witnesses for being here today
congress the fed and treasury acted
boldly in the face of the economic
turmoil brought on by the cobit pandemic
and showcased the true reach of the
federal government's response
through congress's fiscal policy
authority and the fed's emergency
lending facilities
we were able to stabilize markets keep
workers on the job and ensure the
continued functioning
of corporate credit markets as we
continue on the path to economic
recovery it's important
that we take stock of the tools used we
must evaluate which were effective and
which were not
which should be redeployed and which can
be wound down which programs are legally
set to expire
and which programs should be
reauthorized that is the role of this
committee with oversight of the u.s
financial system
i look forward to hearing from our
witnesses on this and other topics to
help inform congress's
continued response to the pandemic
secretary mnuchin and chairman powell
i commend you on your work to promote
economic stability
in turbulent times and i thank you for
your service
i yield back thank you i want to welcome
today's witnesses
to the committee first i want to welcome
the honorable stephen t
minuchi secretary of the united states
department
of the treasury he has served in his
current position
since 2017 mr mnuchin
has testified before the committee on
previous occasions
and i believe he does not need any
further introduction
i also want to welcome our other
distinguished
witness the honorable jerome powell
chairman of the board of governors of
the federal reserve system
he has served on the board of directors
of governors
since 2012 and as its chair since 2018
chair powell has previously testified
before the committee and i believe he
also
does not need any further introduction
without objection
your written statements will be made
part of the record
each of you will have five minutes to
summarize
your testimony when you have one minute
remaining
a yellow light will appear at that time
i would ask you to wrap up your
testimony so we can be respectful
of the committee members times secretary
mnuchin
you are now recognized for five minutes
to present
your oral testimony thank you chairwoman
waters
ranking member mchenry and members of
the committee i'm pleased to join you
today to discuss the department of
treasury's unprecedented response to
support
the american people throughout the
pandemic we continue to work to
implement the historic cares act with
speed efficiency and transparency
but our job will not be complete until
we get every american back to work
when i last testified before you in
september i stated that america was in
the midst of the fastest economic
recovery from any crisis i'm proud to
say while there is still a lot more work
to be done
that statement is true in the third
quarter gdp grew by 33 percent annually
beating all
expectations in a previous record of
1950.
americans are getting back to work the
october jobs report showed the economy
gained back 12 million jobs since april
more than 50 percent of all jobs lost
due to the pandemic
the unemployment rate has decreased to
6.9 a rate not expected
by the blue chip to be achieved until
the fourth quarter
2021. the historic bipartisan cares act
provided
economic relief that is critical to
supporting
the economy recovering additional
economic slowdowns however continue to
impair and cause great harm to american
business and workers
based upon the recent economic data i
continue to believe
that a targeted fiscal package is the
most appropriate federal response
i strongly encourage congress to use the
455 billion in unused funds from the
cares act
to pass an additional bill with
bipartisan support
the ppp has unused money of 140 billion
dollars
that could be sent out the door
immediately to support many small
businesses
the administration is standing ready to
support congress
in this effort to help american workers
in small business
that continue to struggle with the
impact of covet 19.
treasury has been working hard to
implement the cares act in a transparent
and efficient manner
we've released a significant amount of
information on treasury.gov and usa
usaspending.gov
we continue to cooperate with various
oversight bodies including the new
special ig
the treasury ig the treasury ig for tax
administration
the new congressional oversight
commission the gao
we have provided regular updates to
congress marking this my ninth
appearance
before congress for the cares act
hearing we've also devoted significant
resources to responding to inquiries
from numerous congressional committees
and individual members on both sides
we appreciate your interest on these
issues and we remain committed to
working with you to accommodate
congress's legislative purpose to
advance the whole of government approach
to defeating coven 19. share waters i do
want to just
respond to your comment where you said i
had no justification and made matters
worse
on my termination of the facilities i
just want to emphasize this was not a
political decision
i was merely implementing the cares act
i'm happy to walk
you your staff or other members of the
committee through section 4029
which makes it very clear i find it
implausible that any member of the
committee
believed in voting for the cares act
that you are authorizing me to invest
500 billion dollars
in federal reserve facilities to make
loans and purchase corporate bonds
in perpetuity with no expiration date
that is exactly what you would have to
believe if you disagree with my
interpretation of congressional intent
on the issue
and since i was personally there and
negotiated most of these documents i am
very familiar but if congress
wants to extend this money for federal
purposes for these facilities
congress can add that to new legislation
i'd like to thank the members of the
committee for working with us
and i'm pleased to answer any additional
questions thank you very much
thank you very much secretary mnuchin
secretary powell
chair powell you are now recognized for
five minutes to present your oral
testimony
cherry woman waters ranking member
mchenry and other members of the
committee
thank you for the opportunity to update
you on our
ongoing measures to address the hardship
brought by the pandemic
our public health professionals continue
to deliver our most important response
and we remain
grateful for their service federal
reserve
along with others across government is
using its policies to help alleviate the
economic burden
since the pandemic's onset we have taken
forceful actions to provide relief
and stability to ensure that the
recovery will be as strong as possible
and to limit lasting damage to the
economy
economic activity has continued to
recover from its depressed
second quarter level the reopening of
the economy
led to a rapid rebound in activity and
gdp rose at an annual rate of 33
in the third quarter in recent months
however the pace of improvement has
moderated
household spending on goods especially
durable goods has been strong
and has moved above its pre-pandemic
level
in contrast spending on services remains
low largely because of ongoing weakness
in sectors that typically require people
to gather closely
including travel and hospitality
the overall rebound in household
spending is due in part to federal
stimulus payments
and expanded unemployment benefits which
provided essential support to many
families and individuals
in the labor market more than half of
the 22 million jobs that were lost in
march and april have been regained
as many people were able to return to
work as with overall economic activity
the pace of improvement in the labor
market has moderated
although we welcome this progress we
will not lose sight of the millions of
americans who remain out of work
the economic downturn has not fallen
equally on all americans
and those at least able to shoulder
shoulder the burden have been hardest
hit
in particular the high level of
joblessness has been especially severe
for lower wage workers in the service
sector
for women and for african-americans and
hispanics
economic dislocation has upended many
lives and created
great uncertainty about the future
as we've emphasized throughout the
pandemic the outlook for the economy is
extraordinarily uncertain and will
depend in large part on the success of
efforts to keep the virus in check
rise in new covet 19 cases both here and
abroad is concerning
and could prove challenging for the next
few months
a full economic recovery is unlikely
until people are confident that it's
safe to re-engage in a broad range of
activities
recent news on the vaccine front is very
positive for the medium term
for now significant challenges and
uncertainties remain including timing
production and distribution
and efficacy across different groups it
remains difficult to assess the timing
and scope of the economic implications
of these developments with any degree of
confidence
the fed's response has been guided by
our mandate to promote maximum
employment and stable prices for the
american people
along with our responsibilities to
promote the stability of the financial
system
we've been taking broad and forceful
actions to more directly support the
flow of credit in the economy
our actions taken together have unlocked
almost two trillion dollars of funding
to support
businesses large and small non-profits
and state and local governments
since april this in turn has helped keep
organizations from shuttering
and has put employers in both a better
position to keep workers on
and to hire them back as the economy
continues to recover
these programs serve as a backstop to
key credit markets and have helped
restore the flow of credit from private
lenders through normal channels
we've deployed these lending powers to
an unprecedented extent
our emergency lending powers require the
approval of the treasury and are
available
only in very unusual circumstances such
as those we find ourselves in today
many of these programs have been
supported by funding from the cares act
and i have included detailed information
about those facilities in my written
testimony
the cares act assigns sole authority
over its funds to the treasury secretary
subject to the statute's specified
limits limits
the secretary has indicated that these
limits do not permit the cares act
funded facilities to make new loans or
purchases
or purchase new assets after december
31st of this year
accordingly the fed will return the
unused portion of the funds
allocated to the lending programs that
are backstopped by the cares act
in connection with their termination at
the end of the year
as the secretary noted in his letter
non-cares act funds in the exchange
stabilization fund
are available to support emergency
lending facilities if they are needed
everything the fed does is in service to
our public mission
we're committed to using our full range
of tools to support the economy and to
help assure that the recovery from this
difficult period
will be as robust as possible on behalf
of communities
families and businesses across the
country thank you
thank you very much chair paul
i now recognize myself for five minutes
for questions
secretary mnuchin anterior power just
last month the federal open market
committee met and according to the
minutes
quote a few participants noted that it
was important to extend
the emergency lending facilities beyond
year
end that's the quote
a few days later youth secretary mnuchin
requested
that the fed eliminate its cares act
emergency lending facilities
at the end of the year and return 419
billion dollars so that it could not be
used in the future
initially the fed resisted publicly
but the next day chair powell you
acquiesced
secretary mnuchin your own office of
financial research warned that we should
expect and again quote potentially
severe losses
from borrower defaults and bankruptcies
end quote
moreover the outlook for states cities
airports
and hospitals is not good and despite
what president trump
suggests it is not limited to blue
states
for example the day after new york
state's credit
was downgraded mississippi's credit was
downgraded
with the pandemic worse than at any
point since it began
it is foolish and reckless to take away
emergency lending options
at this time secretary mnuchin you agree
you argue rather it was congressional
intent for these fair facilities to be
shut down
at the end of the year but
the law does not say that and even the
actions
of my republican colleagues belie
that novel interpretation senator
mcconnell
filed a covet 19 bill that would change
the law
to require the fed to close all of its
facilities
after january 19 2021
so if law already required this this
bill wouldn't be necessary
the cares act was passed to stabilize
the economy
during the entirety of the pandemic not
until
at the end of your tenure as treasury
secretary
secretary mnuchin it was reported last
week
that you intend to transfer the unused
portion
of the cares act that 500 billion
appropriation to treasurer's general
fund so that the next secretary
can have access to the funds however
section 4027
of the cares act explicitly states
that funds may only be transferred on
january
1st 2026 not before
january 1 2026. what you're doing
is contrary to what is lawful and it
puts our entire
economy in jeopardy and what's more it
has also been reported
that you're working with director
calabria
of the federal housing finance agency
to sell off the government stakes in the
housing
giants fannie mae and freddie mac likely
destabilizing the entire housing market
in the next few months as i understand
it secretary mnuchin
the obama administration showed you
every courtesy when your team was taking
the reigns
similarly the bush administration worked
closely
with president obama's incoming team
during the financial crisis
even before he was sworn in they did so
because they were honoring
the decision of the american electorate
tell me secretary mnuchin and chair
powell
does the secretary's expected successor
janet yellen support what you're doing
does she agree that the emergency
lending facilities
are not needed even though thousands of
people are dying each day
millions more are being infected each
week tens of thousands of small
businesses
are closing permanently and our cities
and states are struggling
does yellen support director columbia's
plans
to fundamentally remake the housing
markets where millions of people
are struggling to pay their mortgage and
rent each month
secretary mnuchin so again let me first
comment on in all due respect uh i
believe i am following the law
section 4029 makes very clear on
december 31st 2020 that the authority
provided
under new loans guarantees or other
investments
shall terminate thank you very much i'm
going to reclaim my time and
do you agree with you where the [ __ ] mr
powell
again the funds let me just continue the
the
transfer of the funds is not up to me
when funds come back they go into
as well in my time i need to have an
answer for mr powell right do you agree
with secretary mnuchin secretary has
sole authority over the cares act
funding
under the cares act the fed is not
involved in that his reading of the law
thus is the authoritative one and we
accept it
i would also just say if i was
politically motivated i wouldn't have
extended the four facilities in
deference to the fed's
view that were non-cares act facilities
so
had i been trying to be political i
would have thank you
my time has expired i now recognize the
distinguished ranking member mr mchenry
for five minutes for questions
well secretary mnuchin um let me just
give you a moment to answer it sounds
like you have additional
additional things you want to explain
and your reading of the cares act
uh the cares act expires on uh december
31st of this year uh that is in the law
uh so let me give you the opportunity to
give a full answer
on your decision with the
exchange stabilization funds
so thank you very much there's three
sections i direct people to
40 29 which is the termination date of
december 31st of 2020
to make new loans loan guarantees or
other investments will terminate that's
perfectly clear
there's section 4003 which references
deposit of proceeds so when proceeds
come in we allocate proceeds whether
it's the return of an airline loan
or money from the fed we allocate it
very clearly in section 4003
there's also as the chair reference
section 4027.
which references if there was money left
over okay and there's limited uses of
what that money can be
either expenses or follow-on investments
to uh on existing loans so if we had to
make an advance
on an existing loan to an airline that's
under 40
27 and any money on 2026 will come back
vis-a-vis that so again uh section 4003
section 4027 section 4029
and again i personally negotiated this
language
uh and again congress has the ability to
change this
if they think the money should be spent
otherwise secretary mnuchin you and i
talked regularly during those
negotiations
i was a strong advocate for as large a
an exchange stabilization fund
uh dollar amount as possible so that
uh both the treasury and the federal
reserve would have
maximum firepower to put out um
what we did not fully understand
um would be what would happen in the in
the coming weeks or coming months with
the nature of the virus
and so we in the in the midst of this
negotiation
had a very very large exchange
stabilization fund
uh absent the care is 454 billion
dollars in the exchange stabilization
fund
how how many dollars uh are uh allocated
to the exchange stabilization fund
again we we allocated uh something like
20 billion dollars from the esf
for the pre-cares facilities prior to
the cares act
as i said in deference to the fed those
facilities don't have this restriction
and still exist and there's still
something like you know an additional 50
billion dollars that could be used in
the future
for emergencies which would support
another
500 billion and again i want to thank
congress
for giving extraordinary authority to
the secretary of the treasury for 500
billion dollars as people have noted
many people criticized uh that authority
and i'm merely following the law and
returning
uh that authority back as congress
intended so
uh chairman powell um these facilities
of the fed uh
served a very important purpose in the
early days
their utilization in recent months had
not significantly changed in dollar
value of uh fed lending facilities
um and so the four remaining facilities
uh are still important as a lender of
last resort facility of course
um and so i i want to thank you for your
work
um to to stand up those facilities
and and your work in the last um
in the last uh eight months of this year
to stand up more facilities than were
stood up in the fullness of the la
of the financial crisis of 2007 2008
2009
2010 uh you used to have more facilities
in eight months well actually in three
months than they did in four years
so thank you to you the staff of the
federal reserve
for their solid great work to support
our economy
and to ensure that this health crisis
that's become an economic crisis
did not become a financial crisis i want
to commend you for that
finally i i want to note um
that i i have consistently been an
advocate of the independence of the
federal reserve
for making monetary policy and
supporting our economy uh i do think
it's important
an important hallmark whether it was uh
chair yellen
and your seat chairman powell or your
service
as chairman of the federal reserve that
we honor the
uh the independent policy-making um
and monetary policy decisions of the
federal reserve and i want to thank you
for your leadership
guilt back thank you very much
the gentleman from guam mr san nicolas
who is also the vice chair of the
committee on financial services is
recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair chairman powell
and uh secretary mnuchin thank you so
much for
making time to be with us here today um
i wanted to open up some questions
regarding the main street lending
program
um mr chairman of do you are you
familiar with how much
has been um authorized uh for the mslp
at this time
yes i am we made about five billion
dollars in loans a little better than
five billions
in the loans okay so we have about five
billion
out there in mslp now that those um
those programs are administered by
participating uh
banks that's correct yes
are the banks um we put it this way we
work through the banking system we
access
borrowers through the banking system you
know we we administer the overall
program but
the banks are facing off against the
actual borrowers
right and um and so these borrowers that
are get um
receiving these mslp funds are they
required to uh
be investment grade borrowers
no and that that
just brings me full circle mr chairman
because the last we spoke
i was discussing the municipal liquidity
facility and the um
fed's inability to allow uh
municipalities that are below investment
grade to be able to access that
liquidity
and it was mentioned in our hearings
that the
federal reserve does not provide funding
to non-investment-grade entities
and yet through the mslp indirectly the
federal reserve as you've mentioned
is willing to do so for private sector
entities
so as you'll recall we um the
the territories there are no investment
grade uh overall
sovereign uh investment grade but we
work with you and your office to
to work with one of the below sovereign
level
facilities and the name of it doesn't
come to mind and we also worked with you
to
to be in touch with the treasury
department under various loan programs
that might be
useful but no we we uh the overwhelming
majority of um
of municipal borrowers are investment
grade and we did limit the facility to
that
well the reason why i'm raising this
point mr chairman is because
i just wanted to highlight the um
inconsistency in the policy
because if investment grade is a
requirement for the federal reserve to
be providing financial support
particularly as the lender of last
resort um
and it's not re and it's not imposing
that same requirement
on private sector entities that are
accessing the mslp
uh i again beg the question why are we
doing so for
municipal entities trying to access the
municipal liquidity facility
i appreciate your staff trying to work
with us in
looking for workarounds um in this um
environment but i mean it's just so
glaring mr chairman
that um these private companies are not
investment grade they're able to access
the support i'm glad they are
i want them to but we're not allowing
municipal
amenities who are not investment grade
to be able to access
the specific facilities that we set up
for our municipal um
our municipal circumstances so i just
wanted to put that on the record mr
chairman i'm hoping that you guys can
again go back to the table and
reconsider this given
given these uh these issues that we're
bringing to light
and at the end of the day we need a
solution for our municipal
um entities that are below investment
grade
but are in the same boat as all these
private sector entities
that are able to access capital through
the mslp thank you madam chair and i
yield back
thank you very much the gentlewoman for
missouri ms
wagner is recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chairwoman and uh
welcome
secretary mnuchin and uh chairman
powell i'd like to
uh thank you both and your
your staff uh for your service to uh to
our nation
and your tireless efforts during this
pandemic to
implement the cares act
and for propping up the federal
reserve's emergency lending
facility while economic data continues
to trend
in a positive direction and we do know
that
that a credible and safe vaccines
are just weeks away the surge
in cases and lockdowns occurring across
the country could result in our economy
backsliding again if we do nothing
i want to reiterate the urgency
the overdue urgency for congress to
provide
immediate targeted relief now
not next year should have been months
and months ago
our nation's hospitals small businesses
uh schools many of our hardest hit
industries
and certainly the uh continued
unemployed cannot continue to wait any
longer for relief
just this week st louis county which i
have the privilege of representing
reported an average of 660 new cases
being added
every day with a total of 51
324 confirmed coronavirus cases as of
sunday many of my constituents in
missouri second
districts are under mass mandates
and restaurants and bars have been
completely
shuttered and are closed down capacity
limits
of gatherings are down to 10. our
families
and our businesses are asking congress
for additional
relief to combat this health crisis
hospitals are filling up and many
businesses are worried that they will
not survive they are reaching the
desperation point
we must stop playing partisan politics
and come to a bipartisan agreement to
provide a direct
covet related stimulus and support
now chairman powell according to the
data you are seeing
what parts of our economy are most in
need of fiscal stimulus
measures provided by by congress
thank you i think there are many sectors
that could use some help and of course
those decisions are really up to you in
the administration but
i'll just mention quickly uh i would
start with the labor market
i think we ought to remember that
despite the rapid progress in getting
people back to work which is so welcome
there's still
10 million people who are out of work
because of the pandemic
and uh you know that's that's more than
lost their jobs in all of the global
financial crisis 10 years ago which at
the time was the biggest
you know uh recession that we'd had in a
long long time so
there's a lot of work left to do there
the unemployment insurance programs are
expiring at year end i think that's an
area where i would certainly look
another that comes up all the time in
our discussions is smaller businesses
and uh what you know we we met with a
group of
community bankers a week or so ago and
and they were telling us
they're just a lot of smaller businesses
in their communities that will struggle
to make it through this winter because
as you say
in missouri second district it's true
it's true all over the country
covet is moving up um and uh
the cold weather people are staying in
and it's going to be tough on a lot of
small businesses that's another place
where
i would look the last is um i do think
state and local governments and this
differs state to state but
they they've had revenue you know
revenues down and
and uh maybe not so much in some states
but in some states
by a lot but costs going up and i think
that they deliver critical services
they're
they're living under balanced budget
requirements and so they lay people off
and they've laid off more than a million
people already
so that's another area where i think it
would be profitable to look
thank you i appreciate that secretary
mnuchin
i'll ask you a similar question you've
mentioned the need for
a targeted fiscal package with the 455
billion dollars in unused funds from the
cares act
that did need to be returned to treasury
given the law um
how do you suggest we can tap or we
appropriate this money to support
the most vulnerable of our anything
my single highest priority would be to
activate the 140 billion in ppp
funds that are not spent that we could
immediately send out
to the hardest hit small businesses
whose revenue
is down dramatically i also think
congress
should consider extending some of the
unemployment
insurance programs that expire at the
end of the year
i appreciate that and uh the paycheck
protection program
is estimated to have saved more than 50
million jobs including many jobs across
missouri's second congressional district
the adventure latest time has expired i
thank you
is recognized for five minutes
i'm sorry took a little bit of time to
get off me there thank you very much
um we really appreciate you all being
here today
was i was really pleased that the
federal reserve's financial stability
report identified climate change as a
risk to financial
stability the report stated that
quote different sectors of the economy
and geographic regions face different
risks that will diverge from historical
patterns
it also said that levered financial
institutions may be exposed to losses
from disasters made more likely by
climate change
chairman powell while there's more to
explore about how to incorporate these
risks into modeling
do you think it is appropriate for
financial institutions to incorporate
climate risk into credit risk assessment
let me say this to for starters climate
change is an important issue
i want to say that society's broad
response to climate change
really has to come from elected
representatives i think there is a role
for the fed here
and we're we're working our way through
understanding what that will be but one
one thing is the public will expect that
in our supervision and regulation of
financial institutions and financial
market infrastructure that they will be
resilient
we'll make sure that they are resilient
to climate change risks
and i do think that that it does fall on
banking institutions and
ccps and other financial market
infrastructures to
evaluate that and incorporate
incorporate uh
in their own operations and also i would
think ultimately in in
in the credit that that they extend
so i think i'll take that as a yes
because i was really appropriate for
financial institutions to incorporate
what role the fed has is of course a
separate question
um i certainly agree with you and and i
asked the question because i am really
concerned with the occ's latest rule
that would prevent banks from
integrating climate-related risks into
their credit assessments
despite the fairly significant financial
risk that climate process
the occ rule specifically says that the
risks of lending quote
would not change based on the sector in
which the firm operates
which is categorically false i don't
know how you would how you would tell
banks that somehow they need to ignore
the dynamics in a sector without
imposing significant systemic risk on on
the banking sector
allowing banks to account for the sector
of the economy where it sits and just
defies logic and market fundamentals
the report also stated that within the
financial system
increased transparency through improved
measurement and disclosure would improve
the pricing of climate risks what
additional transparency would be helpful
to appropriately assess the overall risk
the financial system due to climate
change
so as you can tell i'm glad you read
that box in our financial stability
report
um we're really at the beginning of of
the process of thinking our way through
these things and
so are other market regulators and
central banks and financial institutions
around the world so
um the point there was that we need
we're going to need transparency
uh about about how financial
institutions are thinking about these
risks how they're incorporating in their
business model
we don't actually regulate uh
transparency you know
that's really more of a market regulator
job is to what what is the required
disclosure
i think we're all moving in that
direction but it's it is
in terms of um the interaction between
financial regulators and financial
institutions were at the beginning of
the work
would would a standardization of climate
related risk disclosures from publicly
traded companies be
useful for you in order to continue that
work
[Music]
so i think that's certainly where we're
headed over time again again it's not
our responsibility that would be the
the the market regulator's
responsibility but i do think that's
that's where we'll be going
thank you and i yield back the balance
of my time
thank you uh the gentleman from kentucky
mr barr
is recognized for five minutes thank you
madam chair
uh chairman powell um some in the
press this morning and some of my
colleagues have seen to
uh try to um make the argument that that
you and the treasury secretary are in
disagreement about the exchange
stabilization fund i don't i don't
detect much of a disagreement what i
what i hear
the secretary say is that uh that his
decision to not extend the 430 billion
left in the
exchange stabilization fund is is rooted
in his
interpretation of the statute of the
cares act
and uh what i heard you say is that uh
that you believe that the secretary
under the law has a
has the authoritative interpretation of
that and you accept that
um now obviously you stated yesterday
that
you think it's perhaps premature to be
pulling back from emergency lending
programs but
i i hear the treasury secretary say that
that's within
congress's ability to to authorize that
so i don't see a disagreement here
but given the the modest take-up in some
of the emergency lending programs
particularly main street
wouldn't it be wise for congress to
repurpose at least some
of that 430 billion dollars towards
what admittedly has been an effective
program the paycheck
protection program i hope you won't mind
if i use uh
just a couple seconds to clarify the
sure what's going on so
as i said earlier the secretary has sole
authority over cares act funds he reads
the statute
and reads it to say that there's no uh
no support for lending after december 31
we accept that we don't have a role in
reading
it and uh so that's one thing
our thinking is is not about the cares
act money it is more about
support for the economy we were
concerned that the public might
misinterpret this
as the fed stepping back and thinking
that our work is done and that that's
very much not the case so
we needed to send a signal to the public
to that effect
and as the secretary pointed out in his
letter as we pointed out in our letter
there is
exchange stabilization fund money that's
available to cite
to support the re-establishment of these
facilities or other facilities
if they are needed and and and you know
they meet the legal requirements and
that kind of thing let me just
just ask this though wouldn't it be wise
for congress at this
point before the end of the year to
repurpose some of those
cares act funds uh towards the paycheck
protection program given
the concerns of the small businesses
that you referenced i would just say
that i i
you know what i'm hearing from across
across the aisle and
on both sides of the hill is the desire
to do something to fund these
these causes that the secretary just
talked about and others and i think
i think that would certainly be a help
for the economy as to where that money
comes from that's really up to you well
one area
where there's i think significant
bipartisan support is for streamlining
the forgiveness process um a recent
survey uh in kentucky found that 27
percent of community banks in kentucky
would not participate
in a new round of ppp without
streamlined forgiveness and clear rules
of the road
many of the businesses in my district
who have applied for forgiveness tell me
that the process from the sba is slow
and cumbersome
it's a big problem if lenders will not
participate in the second round because
of
uh inadequate streamlining of the
forgiveness rules
um secretary mnuchin you previously
indicated your support for legislation
to streamline ppp forgiveness
is this still the case and what more can
we do to ensure participation
by community lenders in a new round of
ppp
i do support that and we've created
three different forms
for forgiveness uh using what
authorities we have
and uh making it as simple as possible
for loans that are less than fifty
thousand but
i know there's bipartisan support to
pass a bill i believe it's all loans 150
000
or less and and we fully support that
subject to audit
thank you uh chairman powell uh the
statutory language in the cares act
temporarily suspends accounting rules
related to troubled debt restructurings
uh and that expires on december 31st
it's important that congress extend this
important tool to allow lenders to
continue to work with their customers
what authorities do you have at the fed
to extend
tdr relief administratively versus what
congress must do to ensure lenders
can continue to accommodate borrowers so
we actually don't have authority to
extend tdr it's an accounting role
um we we have a lot of authority though
and we will use it to make sure that
banks continue to work with their with
their borrowers and encourage them to do
so i should say
there's some uncertainty among the
auditing community about whether life
insurers would
qualify for tdr relief under cares uh
this is a problem because insurers make
up over 13
of the commercial real estate lending
market a sector that's deeply impacted
by the pandemic
chair pal do you agree that life
insurers given their participation in
the
commercial real estate lending market
should qualify for tdl relief
i i'd have to go check on that one i'll
come back to you thanks okay
we think that's that's an important
thing to look into uh my time is
expounded yield back
well thank you very much the gentleman
from new jersey
mr gothheimer is no recognized for guide
me
thank you thank you secretary mnuchin
for being here today
the copa 19 pandemic as we've been
talking about has caused
ongoing global health and economic
crisis while certain aspects of our
economy are recovering millions of
americans and thousands of my
constituents
are in dire need of help we can't go
home
from washington with giving given what's
going on and without risking a double
dip recession
as you said earlier this month chairman
powell further support is likely to be
needed
to avoid another spread of the virus and
help individuals we're obviously in the
lame duck session of congress the
american people have waited long enough
our families our businesses and our
communities are all suffering and it
would be unconscionable
for any party to walk away from so many
who are hurting right now
yesterday the problem solvers caucus
joined a bipartisan group of senators in
releasing a new 908 billion dollar
emergency short-term stimulus package it
is intended to be a critical down
payment
get through the next months if i can
start with you uh secretary mnuchin
have you had a chance to review the
framework by chance
well first let me just say i really
appreciate the work that you have
personally done
and the problem solvers have done in
trying to reach
bipartisan solutions i i did review it
briefly yesterday after my testimony and
i'll be
spending more time on it today again i
would i would urge congress to move
quickly on the ppp which there seems to
be enormous bipartisan support but again
thank you personally for your efforts
thank you mr secretary and i appreciate
the work we've done together on this and
obviously
i hope this would be something that if
we can get the support here that the
administration
might support um uh can you
if i could turn to chairman powell uh
would you speak to
the urgency for fiscal relief and and
what do you believe at stake this winter
for the economy and for families if we
don't get
an emergency package done in the next
week
my view would be that it would be very
helpful and very important
that there be additional fiscal support
for the economy
uh really to get us through the the um
the winner this um
we think we've made a lot of progress
faster than we expected and
uh now we have a big spike in covet
cases and
uh it um it may weigh on economic
activity
people may pull back from activities
that were being involved
and we're not into new activities so i
think it would be helpful
uh if we could get that done if you
could get that done
thank you so much uh just follow up on
that
um obviously local governments are
struggling now through no fault of their
own it's putting law enforcement
firefighters keepers
and their people on the line um what do
you think the impact would be
if we can't get extra resources to our
state and local governments
on the economy
um so this these are really decisions
for you but i would say that
state and local governments provide
critical services you mentioned them
and state and local governments live
with balanced budget requirements unlike
the federal government and so what
happens when
when revenues soften and expenses go up
as you see layoffs
and that was a big part of the story in
the slow recovery
the global financial crisis a decade ago
we now have
a little more than a million in in
layoffs
so far and so i i think it would be
important to
um standalone governments are one of the
very largest employers
in the country and they provide those
critical services i think that's a
worthy place for you to look
in terms of where support might be
appropriate
do you see it as sort of just a thought
on that point a ripple effect you've got
in new jersey
about a third of our businesses already
small businesses already gone out
including about 28 of restaurants when
you add that with the with the
revenue declines for the state local
government and all these businesses
coming out
what do you see on the other side of our
and again
but what what the economic uh
with this that this brings along after
uh after the
so i think as you suggested say you have
a near term
and medium term difference the near term
does look challenging through the winter
small businesses we're hearing all over
that small businesses are really under
pressure
and then sometime in the middle of next
year it really does look like
that may be the light at the end of the
tunnel we all hope so
and that the economy could be could be
very healthy the problem is of course
people who lose their homes now or or
businesses that go out of business
these are these are sometimes small
businesses that might have
generations of you know uh of sort of
human capital built up
in in in their activities and once
they're gone they can't just
be recreated so you could lose um
parts of the economy and that will that
will mean a slower recovery and so i
think i mean i like to think of it as a
bridge
over this chasm that was created by the
uh
by the pandemic you know we're trying to
get as much of the economy as many of
the workers across that bridge to the
post-pandemic economy and we've done
i think well at that but there's still
some work left to do
thank you so much i yield that the
gentleman's term has expired
the gentleman from ohio mr gonzalez is
recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair for holding this
hearing and thank you both for for all
your work
uh throughout this pandemic i i
sincerely believe that we'll look back a
decade two decades from now
uh and and the work that you two did
together uh
will be looked at in the most favorable
light
and so i couldn't be more grateful for
your service so thank you both for that
um look we can see the light at the end
of the tunnel with with two vaccines
awaiting approval and i think that the
bridge comment is exactly correct
uh we're looking to bridge from now
until call it you know april 1st or
whenever that is
um and i was pleased to join a group of
bipartisan and bicameral members
yesterday as
as my colleague mr guttheimer just just
mentioned
with the prom solvers caucus to to
hopefully provide that bridge
and and i hope we'll be able to do that
um mr powell
chairman powell before i move into some
questions on that um
going back to the exchange stabilization
fund a bit uh
the main purpose was to provide
liquidity to the financial system to
stabilize
the financial system um as these
programs expire
do you see the same or similar risks to
the liquidity
inside the financial system as you did
say back in march or april
or do we feel like we're in a much
better place today
we're clearly in a much better place i
mean be to be clear the utilization in
these facilities
most of them has is very very low now
nonetheless that we think we see them as
serving a backstop
function and that backstop function you
know
a central banker would want to would and
we would want to leave that backstop and
function
function in place for some additional
period of time not forever you know we
if you look back at what we did
in the global financial crisis we left
them out there until the we were
well past the difficulty and then we put
them unplug them and put them in the
attic
and and put them away none of them
became a permanent feature of the
landscape and we hope these don't either
so that's the way we think about it
thank you that's helpful and hopefully
as we debate a next package
we can consider that uh secretary
mnuchin and in recent months we've heard
speaker pelosi on multiple occasions
state effectively that nothing is better
than something uh with with respect to
additional relief um in your estimation
is nothing better than something for my
constituents back home
no something is clearly better than
nothing
and again i would urge congress to do
something
if it's just the ppp or more
of course that's an obvious statement
which i think everybody knows
um but uh for whatever reason uh this
the speaker has
has chosen that path um my understanding
is
you have continued dialogue with her um
i'm not going to ask you to divulge sort
of specifics of those conversations but
you've been involved in a lot of deals
in your life
uh certainly as as treasury secretary as
you've had these discussions how would
you characterize them with respect to
willingness to actually get a deal done
because i think there's a lot of people
who
like to talk around here um but when it
gets down to it
actually don't do that much with respect
to closing the deal
um how would you characterize the
discussions well
i would say the good news is when we
really needed to get this done
uh last march it got done with
overwhelming bipartisan support
republicans and democrats
came together in an unprecedented
response
when we needed to extend the ppp people
came together
in an unprecedented response
unfortunately since that period of time
things that in my opinion there should
be
absolute bipartisan support and we could
get done unfortunately
uh the speaker has had you know a half a
loaf
is not good enough and wanted to follow
so again i would encourage congress
particularly over the next few weeks in
the lame duck let's try to get something
done
yeah no i i couldn't agree more and and
i
again to state another obvious point um
my colleagues on the other side of the
aisle are in the majority and
in order for this to actually get done
uh
we're all gonna have to come together to
do it but really the pressure needs to
come from them
uh and and i hope that that they will
use the leverage that they have
to encourage the speaker to put a real
bipartisan bill forward
because as chairman powell said as you
said
as common sense demands uh it is obvious
that we need a bridge here that there
are people struggling there are small
businesses struggling there are people
who are unemployed who are struggling
and i can almost guarantee you to the
person
that every single one of them would
prefer something to nothing
and and i hope that this body will come
to common sense
and actually get that done and with that
i yield back thank you
and uh i object to all of the thought
being placed on the speakers
i would advise the president to get
involved and get off the golf course
ms zachary you're now recognized for
five minutes
thank you chairwoman and thank you both
for being here
uh as we all know we're in uh dire
straits right now iowa's now had
increasing unemployment claims for six
straight weeks
and i've of course i'd like to remind
everybody that we need to pay attention
to the level of unemployment
not just the direction this is all
happening when week after week we see
initial claims higher
than the worst that we saw in the great
recession that's 36 weeks in a row
where we've seen record unemployment
claims across this country
meanwhile the century foundation
recently estimated 12 million people
would lose their unemployment benefits
the day after christmas if we don't act
that seems
very terrible for this country chairman
powell what are the economic impacts of
removing that support
at a time when this recovery is so
fragile
so this is if the unemployment programs
run out and expire at the end of the
year i
you know we would be concerned that um
the unemployment rate for people in the
bottom quartile for example is about 20
still and those are people with
relatively low savings low wealth and we
would be concerned that
they'd be vulnerable to uh you know
losing their houses and and
or or their or their rental and just be
in a very difficult place so
um we think that's an appropriate place
to look for uh for further help
well i appreciate that um as we all know
one in eight americans are going hungry
more than three million businesses have
closed and we're approaching a hundred
thousand people now
uh hospitalized with covid so i'm
wondering for either one of you does
seeing this kind of need and the
discussion that we've had today show the
importance of passing
another coved aid package and and how
quickly do you need
do we need to get that done
i i would just urge as uh as the
secretary has done uh that uh this is
this is a good time this would really
help the economy uh through
these uh these winter months and beyond
and um
we again we can see uh the pen we can
see the vaccines coming
but we have a we have a bit more of the
bridge to build
and uh i think it would be very
important for the
economy to receive that help and then
i would agree with that as i've echoed
thank you and secretary mnuchin i did
want to discuss the cdc's eviction
moratorium that currently expires on
december 31st
um a study recently showed 40 430 000
cases of covid
and more than 10 000 deaths are due to
lifting the earlier state and local
eviction
moratorium are there plans to extend
that to possibly protect 10 million
households from eviction this january
well i think you know that wasn't our
first choice our first choice was really
assistance to those people but i i will
discuss that with the president and
extending it and share waters
i have been speaking to the president
every day and updating him on
the state of the negotiations he would
like us to see additional funding
thank you i hope we can get that done
quickly we don't have uh so that we
don't have a 20-day gap year where
millions of people
are going to get evicted so please get
back to us and the chairwoman on what we
can expect from that thank you
um i'd also like to discuss what you're
doing with the 450 billion dollars of
funds for the cares act i know we've had
some discussion here
um i'm going to set aside the question
of whether or what you're doing is legal
because i want to get into why you're
doing this
one explanation i've seen is that
because you think congress should use
this for fiscal aid
and i don't disagree with that the
problem with this though
is that if congress wants to
reappropriate money from the exchange
stabilization fund
we can do that the same as we can from
the general fund so the only real
difference i can see is that leaving it
in the esf
makes it a heck of a lot easier for a
future treasury secretary to use this
money
quickly to provide for economic support
so
why are you choosing to make it harder
to support the economy in the future
i i just want to clarify because there's
a bunch of confusion whether it sits in
the general account whether it's since
in the esf
all of this is completely governed by
the law and as i've said
the chair in deference to him i extended
the pre-cares act facilities if i was
looking to do something that was
political
i wouldn't have extended those my my
in not extending the cares act is merely
an administration of my obligation under
this law it doesn't matter
what account it's in that has nothing to
do the money is administered
pursuant to the law and if congress
wants to change the law
that that's fine and the reason why i
believe mitch mcconnell
has put some new language in isn't in in
my interpretation of the law it's
because many of you is
reclaiming my time
thank you a secretary but that's just
not accurate the cares act is very clear
that existing investments can remain
there and that's what you've made happen
with the fed's facilities
so that answer isn't acceptable why are
you looking for a way not to help
american people right now
this isn't your money it's taxpayer
money and it should be quickly available
to american people
right now when we need to help so i see
you undermining the american people on
your
door you need to reverse this decision
so that these programs can keep
the agency thank you for your service
and i yield back
thank you the gentleman from tennessee
mr rose
is recognized for five minutes thank you
chairwoman waters and and ranking member
mchenry
and i thank uh you uh secretary mnuchin
and chair powell for being here today
and for this third
oversight hearing required by the cares
act i want to thank you also for the
great work by both the department of the
treasury and federal reserve
throughout this pandemic response your
fast action has allowed businesses
in my district in tennessee and across
the country as well to keep their doors
open
and employees on the payroll i also want
to underscore
the importance and impact of the cares
act on stabilizing the economy we
continue to see
strong economic recovery and i hope we
can continue that trend as we work
towards the great
american comeback congress has already
provided approximately 1 trillion
through bipartisan legislation including
the cares act to stabilize state
and local economies and support
communities including front line workers
teachers students school employees
and employers and employees in your
testimony you pointed out that 455
billion
in unused funds remain from the cares
act
back in tennessee folks are talking
about how these funds sit
unused while house democrats continue to
discuss spending
an additional 3.4 trillion and that is
with a t
trillion in the heroes act in middle
tennessee there have been
several industries that are enjoying
their best year ever
while others have been completely
devastated by the government
imposed shutdowns due to the coronavirus
pandemic
the american private bus and motor coach
industry is one of the latter the motor
coach industry plays a vital role in our
travel
tourism and music industries and
provides nearly 60
million or i'm sorry 600 million
passenger trips per year
in the wake of the pandemic nearly all
of the 3 000 companies in the industry
at some point were completely
shut down 36 000 vehicles were parked
and most of the over 88 000 employees
were laid off
we have billions of dollars sitting
unused and yet this industry
still needs relief congress must act to
provide
targeted relief secretary mnuchin as a
proponent yourself of targeted relief
can you detail what you would do to
provide
targeted aid to this devastated industry
yes and let me just say there's more
than the 450 billion unused there's
actually another 140 billion in
ppp on top of that but i would support
20 billion dollars in additional money
in payroll support to the airlines
identical to what we've done before
in the cares act i think that would be
very meaningful
in terms of employment and saving the
industry
and i appreciate that but unfortunately
that assistance
didn't reach the motor coach industry
and so they have
not had enjoyed that same targeted
relief that we saw go to the airline
industry do you believe that uh the aid
that you described should be included
in an end-of-year package
i i apologize i i thought you were
asking about the airline so i
i would support additional aid to motor
coach
as well thank you lastly would you be
willing to commit to having treasury
staff brief
my staff and senator marcia blackburn
staff before the end of the year
on ways that treasury might be able to
provide
targeted assistance to the bus and motor
coach industry using
any existing funds
we'd be happy to i don't think
unfortunately we can use existing funds
but we'd be more than happy to go
through that with your staff
thank you thanks to president uh trump's
operation warp speed
and the great american innovative
industries that we have
we are getting closer and closer to
widely distributing a vaccine
in tennessee if the fda authorizes
emergency use
we are expecting to see distribution
beginning in mid
december chair powell could you speak to
the effect
distributing an effective vaccine would
have
on our economy
yes well um clearly in the in the medium
term which is to say
uh sometime in the middle of next year
where we're not well positioned to
give a precise estimate of when that
might be people
will regain confidence that it's that
they can gather
in various activities that now seem too
risky because of covid
and that'll have a very positive effect
on
on economic activity on spending on
hiring so
we do see uh very positive things
coming uh i would i just would add
though as i said in my testimony the
the uh sort of path is a little bit
uncertain because
um you know we're still we'll start
we'll we are still learning going to be
learning about the efficacy of the
uh of the uh vaccines and also about the
speed of the rollout and who will get
them in and in what order and what the
effect will be on the public but overall
i think we see a very positive uh set of
developments coming
um at a somewhat uncertain time but not
so long into the future
thank you chairwoman waters i yield back
thank you
the gentlewoman from california ms
porter is recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair chair powell would
you say the economic crisis
caused by the pandemic is over
i'm sorry i couldn't hear exactly what
you said i apologize
it's okay would you say the economic
crisis caused by the pandemic is over
no i would not okay how long do you
think it'll take
before we know
uh i think we'll look well before we
know i think we'll know a lot
uh in the next uh four to six months
about vaccines but
the real issue though is what are going
to be the effects
of people who whose jobs may have
changed or gone away
it's really that the new the
post-pandemic economy is going to be
different
and we're going to learn a lot about
that in the second half of next year and
i i think
those people are going to need help some
of them and i think that's
sheriff hal a very fair answer um we
can't know unless we have a crystal ball
exactly how the recovery from this is
going to proceed
now secretary mnuchin who's also here
with us today
he apparently disagrees with you in fact
secretary mnuchin is so certain that the
economic crisis is over
that he wants to ban the fed from
using any more of the 500 billion
dollars
that congress set aside in the cares act
to help the economy
two weeks ago he wrote to you to request
that you return the remaining 455
billion
because our economy in his opinion
simply doesn't need it anymore
in response you chair powell said
that the outlook for the economy
is extraordinarily uncertain the federal
reserve would prefer that the full suite
of emergency facilities
established during the pandemic continue
to serve their important role
as a backstop for our still strained and
vulnerable
economy needless to say it's highly
concerning that two
that the two people tasked with
stabilizing
our economy do not agree on whether the
markets are stable
but it actually doesn't matter what
either of you two think
because secretary mnuchin simply doesn't
have the authority
to recall the 455 billion
i'm reading aloud now from section 4027
of the cares act
on or after january 1 2026
any funds that are remaining shall be
transferred to the general fund in other
words set
set back to the treasury secretary
mnuchin is it currently
the year 2026 yes or no
first let me comment i do believe
there's an economic emergency
you're putting words in my mouth that
are not correct second of all
okay uh the answer is that 40-27
would you start by asking answering my
question and i will ask you
others is today 20 the year
2026 yes or no
of course it's not 2026 how ridiculous
to ask me that question
or waste our time well secretary mnuchin
i think it's ridiculous that you're play
acting
to be a lawyer when you have no legal
actually i have plenty of lawyers at the
department of treasury who advise me so
uh i'd be more than happy to i'm more
than happy to follow up with chair
waters and explain all the legal
provisions and the ranking member so
more than happy to make that access
secretary mnuchin are you in fact a
lawyer
i do not have a legal degree i have
lawyers that report to me
thank you um chair powell are you
in fact a lawyer
i am uh a former lawyer a recovering
lawyer you have a legal degree correct
yes i do okay so secretary mnuchin
you're trying to tell chairman cowell
to send over any remaining fund right
now
and you're claiming falsely in my
opinion
that that is what the law says and
you've gotten into
disagreement with someone who's actually
a
are you a lawyer congress which actually
wrote the law
about what it says actually i wrote the
law with congress
for what it's worth and by the way it's
not 450 billion is returning i think
it's approximately 175 billion
reclaiming my time there was no question
there
um secretary mnuchin the cares
act already says an exhibit
for in um in section 4027
it says that you have to stop making any
new investments new investments
in fed lending program year end
it doesn't say that the fed programs
must stop
taking loans or purchases you are making
a decision that does not align with the
statute
or congressional intent
the gentlelady's time has expired
the gentleman from wisconsin's mr style
is recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chairwoman uh secretary
mnuchin thank you for being here
uh would you like to further your
comments for just a minute
uh on on the last exchange there is to
your your rationale
i feel like you got cut off therefore
again thank you very much
and again i i think what i will do is
follow up with the chair
and the ranking member so we clarify
both 40 27 and 40 29
again i've had these discussions we